[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i'm going to bring you
somebody familiar
with a very unfamiliar story now
we all know who thanos is
and we all know exactly why
we're here we're here
for side shows
mini bust thanos
now there's many reasons why i even got
this statue
but the main reason is because it it it
seems like it's a companion piece
to thanos on throne
and it's uh made in the same vein but
i'm getting ahead of myself
let me go back to a story about
thanos that many of you probably don't
know about and
it's uh probably the most
leading misleading thanos story
ever written it's called thanos versus
the hulk
so you had thanos and you had the hulk
you knew off the rip the king was in
100 there was absolutely no way
i was not getting this four four-part
mini-series
uh written uh by jim starlin
the creator of thanos so
i got the book and the book is kind of
crazy
because it starts off with pip the troll
which is one of my favorite characters
from um adam warlock you know that whole
cosmic story stuff well he abducts
uh bruce banner and the reason why he
does
uh uh bruce banner is because
annihilus needed something that was
inside the hulk
because the nihilist was like close to
death or something like that
so the story takes the hulk off of earth
uh because picked up troll uh has the
powers like
um nightcrawler if you're familiar with
nightcrawler
he can teleport but he can do it over
vast distances
because he's a cosmic entity a very
funny one at that
so he abducts bruce banner he takes him
there and they
get whatever they want out of him to
help anonymous
but at the same time uh pip the troll
enlists nano's help to free the hulk
because
patrol is so afraid of the avengers
coming to seek revenge against him
so thanos goes and
you would think that his thanos versus
the hulk
but it's absolutely not thanos goes
there
and he goes into bruce banner's
subconscious where the hulk is
and they have like this uh virtual
uh psionic plane fight
really boring really tedious
but at the same time that whatever they
extracted out of the hulk
they made sure that they put it inside
the list and a nihilist
uh is coming back from near
death and he has hulk size proportions
so the hulk breaks free from the machine
with the help of thanos
and then the hulk goes on a rampage
annihilus uh
wakes up tries to fight the hulk and
they fight and they fight and they fight
and all this was to set up i think is
thanos initiative or imperative
initiative
something of that nature but one of the
most misleading comic books that i've
read
and i love jim stalin's artwork so i was
just like i chalked this one up as
clickbait baby so it is what it is
but let's get into the statue now
this this this statue this mini bus
because usually bus is like one full
scale i mean one half skill or or one to
one scale
real really big right like like my iron
man
well this one is made like the thanos on
throne
in the same liberties that they took
with the thanos on thrones armor if you
notice the armor on thanos
his armor is a little bit different uh
than his comic book
accurate armor and definitely different
from the mcu's armor
there's the side shows take on his armor
and i find it to be beautiful
but what i've also loved is the fact
that lady death
his love is in the statue
so that made it a must buy for me
now there's a little concern with uh
with a couple of things because if you
have thanos on throne you know the
texture work
on it and the the coloring
the painting is phenomenal there's
different shadings
in the armor that you would see in that
thanos on throne
that you don't see here that's the only
um caveat that i say i have
against it but what i do love
is i love the gauntlet it's a little bit
more detailed
i love that it has a light up feature
the
facial animation and and
the portrait is beautiful on the statue
like when you look into his eyes you can
see space into his eyes
his teeth is really well done this
the grimace that he has is is there
so this minibus captures thanos in all
his glory for me
and i'm going to be displaying it down
there in my thanos shrine
uh so it definitely fit the size
it fit the aesthetic it fit the motif it
fit
everything that i needed for my thanos
uh
you know um shrine you can say
so this is the part in the video when
i'm going to ask you
to like follow and subscribe and also
hit that join button hit that joy button
you know that joint button that join
button is right there at the bottom
so when you join the realm right there
you get access
to all the videos that's in the
background you get a chance to see when
i got the tattoo from will me hood
that guy boy never thought that'd happen
but that's
there and there's also a lot of videos
that we have updated that we post from
pax ease from e3 that's just for the
realm
a behind the scenes look at what goes on
with the iron lords
when we're at all these shows now i
would love for you to go to see
the last word with lol cognito and
ibontes
that is the best damn destiny podcast
that
is in youtube's
history to be honest with me and i'm not
just saying it because
you know low cognito is family
i'm saying it because it's true go check
it out
tell me if i'm wrong put in the comments
let me know
also go to lordsgaming.net where we have
a ton of opinion pieces
uh a slew of writers a lot of writers
doing their best jobs
there to bring you all the information
up to date
as fast as possible about next-gen
consoles
and also the next gem video games and
all the delays and stuff that's going on
yeah i know it sucks halo got delayed
but tell the truth guys
didn't it really need it all right well
tune in next week when i bring you
something that's a little bit faster
than you thought it was
stay collecting
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
do
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
more
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you